hi guys
in this video i'm going to solve another
question from iit jam
biotechnology and this says what would
be the product formed after e2
elimination from this compound so if e2
elimination happens from this compound
which one of these following product
would be formed
the correct option for these
is a again
and this type of question was repeated
in 2016 again so
if we consider this particular bond
so here bromine
is on the top of the plane
and
the ch3 group is bottom of the plane
and there are two possible condition
possible
region from where
hydrogen could be eliminated
and one is
marked by one here
and another
portion is
the deuterium over here
this is the site two
and this is the site one now elimination
would take place from site two
because bromine is
upward from the plane
and
another thing that have that should be
eliminated with bromine should be
downward from the plane not upward here
hydrogen is upward but another deuterium
is downward so bromine would take
deuterium along with it and eliminate it
and form a double bond over here but
here hydrogen is from the top of the
plane same plane as where the bromine
reside
so bromine
would not take this hydrogen instead
bromine would take this deuterium and
get eliminated so a double bond would be
formed over here so the correct option
is this because double bond is over here
and the deuterium was eliminated so
correct option is option a
hope you enjoyed the video and this type
of question is very important and
it was repeated again in 2016
and now you know the tricks how to solve
this type of question just we have to
take clear care of the plane and always
we have to remember that elimination
takes place from the different plane if
one electronegative molecule
electronegative atom is in the top plane
the hydrogen
must be in the downward plane or in the
opposite plane only in opposite plane e2
elimination can take place hope you
enjoyed please like and subscribe